it is a church of christ
it's an amazing gospel choir
kanye west blew us out of the water like
literally
[Applause]
yep that's the rapper seemingly walking
on water with his kids during his sunday
service
the epic visual was held over the
weekend at pinewood forest in
fayetteville georgia
where the data four was seen joining his
choir during the dramatic
entrance
if pastor friends are in town they'll
come and they'll say a few words
kanye teamed up with pastor joel osteen
who gave a sermon about the meaning
behind the illusion
i'm watching these fine men and women
singing looks like they're walking on
the
water and my mind goes back to that time
where
jesus invited peter to walk on the water
yay's wife kim kardashian recorded the
whole event on instagram
she arrived with her bestie lala anthony
and singer monica
look look this way oh turn around
[Laughter]
also in attendance two chains
the event had a total of 150 guests and
is said to have followed coven 19
safety guidelines i feel like i have a
responsibility to innovate and to
to fight for creativity e.t talked to
kim in 2019 about how sunday's service
came about for kanye
for him it started off as something that
was really healing for him and it was
really small
and really personal and it grew and grew
and he really has
been saved by christ and uh it's like
born again
and he dedicates his whole life
to the church it's just become this
amazing thing and i do see online
sometimes people are like well what is
it is it just a gospel choir
do they talk like it is a church of
christ
it is a christian church
and um it's an amazing gospel choir
despite the recent turbulence in the
relationship kim has been showing her
husband
her support i've seen him go through a
lot
in august a source told dt that the
couple was continuing to put their
careers on hold
to focus on their marriage and family
they love one another
and want to work on saving their
marriage at the end of the day
life is about being happy being who you
are and i feel like we are so blessed to
have the best support system and the
best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through